zero-hour as fast have you reached a
decision
yes Houdini did not come through my I do
not believe that Houdini can come back
to me or to anyone after faithfully
following through the ten-year Houdini
compact using every type medium and
field it is now my personal and
originally the spirit communication in
any form it I do not believe that the
oedema shrine has been for ten years I
now reverently turn
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 21 of
the 13 o'clock podcast get out there 21
I know I still can't believe we're on 21
it seems like we just started this I
know I said well you know it's been a
few months but while we're on that
subject yeah don't you start what do you
think the network yes we first of all we
wanted to thank project Entertainment
Network on which our audio version is
hosted yeah he can Trevor worth it yeah
so we've had kind of a lot of a lot of
downloads on there yeah we moved over to
the new network yeah seems like
downloads doubling each month yeah which
is good so thank you guys the ones that
listen to us on project projects
Entertainment Network oh and while I'm
on the subject of them too I wanted to
mention I think I mentioned it last week
but they have a patreon and I'll link to
it on the YouTube video but um you know
on the audio version just go to patreon
and projects Entertainment Network and
you'll find it
throw them a couple bucks it's you know
good for us good for the whole network
good for all the other awesome podcasts
that are on there eventually we'll start
our own patreon probably one to show
these bigger yeah things though so more
people listen listen yeah it's funny cuz
like on the youtubes on our youtube show
we'll have comments boy these this shows
should be getting thousands of hits be
patient okay with every patient and what
use what you're seeing on YouTube is it
doesn't always match up with what you
see on the podcast download you'll see a
show like for instance you know doctor
prices show that we have from biblical
mythology that's getting like almost
4,000 hits which is a lot for a little
show like like ours that's getting like
4000 on YouTube but then you look good
you look at at the download there's any
the podcast and it's may is may be in
the hundreds yeah but then you'll see
another one of our shows like a good
example would be like remember the what
about the radio oh the one despite when
we did the number station number so yeah
number stations didn't like it did too
well but you look at the look at the
podcast and that was like one of our top
show yeah a lot of people downloaded the
audio version so there's a lot of
differences between our YouTube fans and
our iPod or why do I keep saying that I
don't know man I just woke up yeah well
several hours yeah we were just saying
because we I mean generally we just kind
of do shows about random [ __ ] that we
like yeah we find interesting we hope
that other people find it interesting
too like we don't really go around
picking subjects based on what we think
other people will like we just do [ __ ]
we are interested in you and that we
want to talk about and anyway and we may
not even be
experts yeah it's just it's just check
that we like and we're gonna present it
to you guys like oh sometimes we'll get
some real brainiacs on there you know
complaint you know there's a little
cereal on the youtube comment serial
killer fanboys oh we don't know there's
a new book out you guys are wrong and we
don't really care we're just presenting
the general consensus of what that case
was that we're just having a good time
shoots the [ __ ] about it cuz it's
something that we're interested win and
we encourage the audience that if we
present something that you find
interesting to go out and go look you go
study more obviously we're not the
be-all end-all we don't know it's like I
do research for these podcasts but most
of the time it's pretty freewheeling I
miss [ __ ] up all the time I know and and
really cover some of these subjects
would take eight hours right he's only
an hour shifts only an hour show so you
know so you have somebody all simmer
down
yes but the ones yet the ones that you
know who I'm talking to
pipe down yeah yeah you're smarter than
us yeah okay so you know speaking of
topics that I have been wanting to do
this separate this was one of the first
ones this was one of the first topics
that I wrote down this is gonna be a
good show when we first started about
doing about doing podcast and I saw I
even wanted to do this one for a while
and I said oh I'm gonna have to do a lot
of research about this one so I did some
research about if I'm wrong I'm sorry
it's all the little smart asses out
there um but yeah I don't want to do
this in for a long time this one is
about Harry Houdini yeah and
specifically it's about Houdini's kind
of run-ins with the paranormal with the
spiritualist people don't know that
Harry Houdini kind of did his own
paranormal investigations on the side
yeah I mean is Harry Houdini the
paranormal investigator yeah and he was
a he was turned out he ended up being a
debugger because he couldn't find the
real deal yeah
and go ahead go ahead I mean obviously
Harry Houdini's butt is most famous for
being an illusionist being an escape
escape artist still very famous even
though it was the early 20th century but
in the years before he died he became
very interested in spiritualism and
seances and mediums and things like that
later in a debunking capacity yeah now
the interesting thing about Houdini
he was obviously trained as a magician
and he was a skeptic but he was a
skeptic in the classic sense of the word
and that had he seen evidence that
spiritualism was correct that the dead
could really talk to the living yeah
then he would have believed it he wanted
to believe it yeah
in fact the reads the whole reason that
he got interested in spiritualism and
seances in the first place was because
in the early 1920s his mother Cecilia
died and Houdini had been very very
close to his mother he adored his mother
and her death was a huge devastating
blow to him and he initially started
going you know contacting mediums and
see going to seances and things like
that because he was hoping to get a
message from her now what he wanted now
his kind of criteria was he wanted one
of the mediums he said this is all I
will know that the medium is really
talking to her if the medium can tell me
what her last word was before she died
yeah her last word was forgive and he
went to mediums he went to seances and
and no one could ever tell him that word
so after a while he became disillusioned
and also angry because he felt like
these people were taking advantage
of people's grief I think this is a good
time also they got give it give it
background for the times you know to
some of the younger audience yeah this
gets back to almost kinda like we were
Tom of the Nazis and the occult sin the
Thule Society this is pre-internet
people who used to damn entertain
themselves with seances yeah they didn't
have really clubs to go out to no
nightclubs uh there were it was there
was a whole lot to do so spiritualism
became a big fat it was a big fad and it
was it was all throughout all the
Western world as far as I know and then
it actually started in the late 19th
century around the 1840s yeah it
actually started among the Quakers yeah
and it got a big it was bolstered a lot
by the very famous Fox sisters we might
do a show about them at some point who
were supposedly mediums that could
communicate with spirits by a series of
knocking yeah those raps most people
believed people did believe it and that
was kind of the fulcrum that Nev started
the whole spiritualist movement now you
know like I said we might do a show
about the Fox sisters but spoiler alert
many years later they admitted that the
whole thing had been a fraud that they
had been producing the knocks by
clicking that their toe joints yeah they
could click their toe joints really
leverage generations and generations of
people that grew up lived and died
believing in spiritualism parallel to
their religion yes gianna t it was it
was a mirror image of Christianity
around and and there are like actually a
few pockets of spiritual is left in a
matter of fact I'm we're in Central
Florida in Orlando not far from here
there is a community called Cassadaga
and it's a spiritualist community
there's all mediums and stuff I've only
been a couple I was almost Christian
science would probably be almost yeah
it's a similar kind of thing and
Scientology more kind of that but um but
yeah so so Houdini like I said he he was
open to the possibility he wanted it to
be true but because he had kept going to
the seances and you know he was a
trained magician so he could see how
these mediums were achieving these
tricks because most of the tricks were
very simple
you know the seances were usually
attended by people who wanted to believe
that they were talking to dead people
and the seances usually occurred in the
dark which meant that you know the
mediums could you know move things
around when no one could see cuz no one
could see them or they had accomplices
that were hidden in the house and
whatnot
indeed there were usually a very simple
tricks and Houdini could see right
through them so he became very
disappointed and disillusioned and like
I said he became angry with them because
he felt like they were taking advantage
of grieving people
yeah and giving them false hope that
they would be able to communicate with
their loved ones when they were really
just defrauding them yeah it got to the
point where he was publicly vowing to
destroy spiritualism yes forever yeah
and honestly I mean the last he still
did his magic act like in the last few
years of his life but most of his time
was taken up with debunking mediums and
he would even he would tour around the
country and he would show slides of
mediums and then he would explain how
they had done this trick and how they
had done that trick and you know it was
getting to the point where spiritualism
was kind of going down the tank because
he was kind of making them a
laughingstock he was showing how they
were doing all their tricks and he would
also like in some of his later shows he
would actually replicate a lot of the
tricks that you know some of the more
famous mediums were doing and he would
do them on stage and it and this tour
that he did where he did that was like a
huge success like she sold out shows and
they had to add shows I'm not real sure
on a dates did he know anything of
education you know what I don't know
Houdini died in 1926 so it was Casey man
you just pulled something out of my cell
like man I don't know I just thought it
Casey because he would have been a
spiritualist yeah basically similar kind
of thing yeah so basically um you know
so he goes around debunking mediums now
I wanted to talk of a little bit about
the most famous one that he
go ahead so Houdini Scientific American
magazine at the time they asked Houdini
about you know investigating mediums and
they kind of got together on it and
Houdini said well I want to start a
committee you know a scientific
committee we can offer a cash prize for
any medium that can actually you know
talk to the dead we're gonna investigate
it and if we determine that they're
genuine then we will give them the money
now obviously know whatever that's mine
right but in the 1920s Houdini was out
on tour and this the other guys on the
Scientific American community and these
were note they've not slouches mhm it
was two guys from the Society for
psychical research one was a one guy was
a physicist they were you know there
were scientists
these dudes but scientists you know
that's good but they weren't magicians
right like I said Houdini was a magician
can bobble the body yes he knew I mean
he made his living doing these kind of
tricks that these mediums were doing and
he recognized how they were done so he
was out on tour and the rest of the
committee had become very impressed with
this particular medium named Enoch
randon probably better known as Margery
now the guys from the Scientific
American community had investigated her
they'd gone about 20 seances mm-hm and
they thought she was legit okay okay and
they were gonna give her the money
really but Houdini when he heard about
that yeah he was super pissed he's like
you cannot give her the money I have not
investigated her the guys are doing this
[ __ ] without me right yeah and there was
another thing too and this is very funny
I read this in there was
there's a site there's a really good
site about I don't know where it is now
but it's it's all about Houdini and it's
kind of got all the stuff about his life
now Mina Crandon she did not take any
money for her services because she was
married to a very very wealthy surgeon
named Leroy so she didn't need the money
right but it turned out that Mina
Crandon was actually she was a very
pretty woman uh 36 years old flapper she
had a bobbed hair and rush it real
pretty eyes and all this other kind of
stuff now when she did her seances she
would come out dressed in a see-through
kimono okay all right so you know what I
mean and and they said her husband was
kind of her manager hi guys and he would
show like people that came to the
seances he would show up like naked
pictures of her okay like you know
having ectoplasm coming out of her out
of her nose and her mouth and out of her
veg no so there was obviously some kind
of weird [ __ ] going on there now also
but they were charging money no some
kind weird sexual thing
yeah and so it turned out also the
Crandon had a really really nice house
okay and the seances they gave up always
at their nice house
and so all these Scientific American
guys who were all saying yeah she's a
real medium she talked to dead people
you know they had been looking at
pictures of this chicks badge and yes
she and hanging out and they're really
been they're palatial home and eatin all
their nice food everything like that so
you know I bribery kinda yeah it was
kind of like that
so Houdini was kind of pissed off and he
said well he said I'm cutting my tour
short okay and I am coming out there to
investigate her because because you guys
are this is [ __ ]
okay so he comes out there and he goes
to the first seance 1924 it was in
summer and he had done some
investigation into the way she did her
seances he said okay
know that her husband always sits to her
right and whoever the guest of honor is
always sits to her left which will
probably be me and he kind of had an
idea of how she was doing her [ __ ] now
her shtick was she had as many mediums
did at the time she had a spirit guide
his name was Walter and he was supposed
to be the spirit of her dead brother who
was actually crushed to death in an
industrial accident like many years
before and so that was who you know
would would bring the spirit messages or
whatnot and they also did things like
you know standard seance shits like I'll
ring a bell and throw a horn and all
this other kind of crap right so Houdini
kind of had an idea of how how she might
operate so since he figured that he was
going to be sitting on her left he took
his leg and he put a bandage real tight
around it so it swelled up so it was
like really sensitive to skin there
right on the day of the seance so by the
time he went to the seance it was like
real swollen and he sat right next to
her on the left on the left now all the
lights went out and everything like that
now Walter comes through her trance and
whatever and you know Houdini was like
okay now ring this Bell or whatever that
was it was on the floor like under a
table and he clearly felt her leg move
like come out from the bonds and ring it
with her feet you're right yeah okay and
then and then they were like okay we
there was this like horn like a
megaphone and um Walter quote/unquote
asked Houdini where do you want me to
throw it who do you still throw it at
May yeah so you know the horn the horn
did come and had the megaphone to come
in him later he figured out that because
the room was dark yeah all she had done
was got one of her hands-free when no
one could see her put the Horner ahead
and then when he said hey throw it me
she just threw her head you know she
threw her head forward and threw it at
him she he didn't tell this to any of
the Scientific American people at the
time all right but at the end of the
seance he all he told them was I've got
her she's a fraud all right and they
were like how did you hear you heard
like she's awesome and all this other
kind of
up now on the next seance he actually
built a box and made her sit in it but
only her head was and he put everything
inside the box unsurprisingly at that
seance nothing happening right yeah and
so he thought that that was the end of
it right but the Scientific American
guys were still convinced fans is a
powerful weapon I guess but they were
still and they and there was a huge and
there was like a huge argument like
between them yeah so because they still
wanted to give her the money and Houdini
is like what are you talking about she
is obviously a fraud yeah and then there
was just all kind of this crap and they
kept having more seances because the
Scientific American guys were like no we
you see it's like we're having all these
more seances and blah blah yeah um you
know but she did other stuff like the
table would rise Houdini found out that
she was just sticking her head under
there eventually a different Reaper
here's what's weird
he kind of did mm-hmm
but in a way it almost ended up not
mattering yeah because what ended up
happening and okay now here's the weird
thing though now reportedly as they did
more seances because she still wanted
the money this is some of the scientific
American committee wanted to give her
the money but Houdini didn't want them
to so they were fighting and so like
they kept having more seances but at one
of the seance is where nothing was
really happening mm-hmm Marjorie threw
like her spirit guide Walter started
cursing Houdini out said I'm gonna curse
you you're gonna die soon okay and all
this other stuff and now reportedly
later in the press in August of 1926
Walter apparently said Houdini will be
gone by Halloween and Houdini did die on
Halloween yeah so I don't know if that's
true though
but reportedly Walter did curse him yeah
and say he was gonna have a short life
and specifically that's that he was
gonna die that prediction could have
been inserted that's what I mean that
could have been inserted suit looked
more impressive yeah now predictions are
always more accurate when you're
predicting something that already that
already happened exactly
exactly yes so you know the thing is her
um you know she still had a lot of
defenders even though many years later
it came to light that actually one of
the Scientific American guys who had
been on the committee was helping her Oh
complex yeah they were to divide the
money yeah what I'm thinking no she
never did get the money money now she um
she kind of descended into alcoholism
yeah later on um but like I said she
still had defenders right um you know
she was still married to a rich guy so
it's like it didn't really matter to her
I guess um but spiritualism was kind of
on the wane by the time she died in 1941
okay so um you know her reputation not
so great at the end but you know she's
got pretty young men uh yeah she did it
she was only 36 I think the when okay so
she's not 60 yeah so Dan in 19 in the
1920s she was 36 but um you know so now
the the case of Marjorie
was actually kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back also between
Houdini and Sir Arthur Conan Doyle yeah
tell us about this now should I take a
break first cuz that's kind of a long
story
well you got about ten minutes all right
so like I said this was this kind of
spelled the end of their friendship
however their friendship had been
getting kind of tense in the years
before the whole marjorie
debacle debacle tell us how these two
men throw the code
we met in the 1920s now as most people
who know famously Sir Arthur Conan Doyle
was a big advocate of spiritualism yeah
and he was a writer he was a writer and
his wife was a medium also lady Jean and
despite this he wrote Sherlock Holmes he
did he did now in his later years he
didn't write as much because he got so
into spiritualism that he started
touring the world like lecturing about
how awesome it was and all this other
stuff so um so he was big into it now
you wouldn't think that him and Houdini
would have got along but they actually
kind of did Houdini kind of admired him
because you know even though he thought
spiritualism was false
he said well here's an intelligent
person that's in the spiritual ISM that
can defend his beliefs even though I
disagree and Arthur Conan Doyle actually
kind of admired Houdini's debunking of
mediums but not for the same reason that
Houdini was doing it Arthur Conan Doyle
said oh well we need to get rid of the
fraudulent ones yeah so the real ones
can rise to the top yeah that's good
thinking ya know I mean Houdini thought
they were all frauds
right yeah but Arthur Conan Doyle didn't
really think that but he's but he
admired Houdini's like well you're just
you're getting rid of the [ __ ] he was
Doyle's figuring will get well if some
of them have to be real yeah eventually
we'll just get rid of fakes and that
real ones will be there and that will
prove that that'll prove it yeah the
world and I mean they used to like I
said they had actually a very good there
was a lot of mutual respect I mean they
had arguments but you know they they
respected each other's viewpoints
now Houdini was kind of adamant and
trying to show Arthur Conan Doyle that
all of these you know all of these
things that these mediums were doing
could be replicated by a magician but
that kind of ended up backfiring because
Arthur Conan Doyle was so into he's so
believed in spiritualism that he's like
even if you can show me that every
single
can be replicated that doesn't mean that
it's still not real these people can't
really do it just because you can do it
right by physical means but the funny
thing is him and some a bunch of other
spiritualist that he knew like in his
circle they actually thought that
Houdini was a medium and was and that he
didn't really know it or that he didn't
want to tell anyone tell anybody
yeah the Arthur Conan Doyle actually
publicly said dee dee's a medium that
the reason that Houdini could do all
these because many years before Houdini
had kind of become famous for going
around the country and challenging
police departments to lock him up in
their most inescapable cell and he would
get out like I said I can get out of
anything I can get out of leg shackles
anything now a hurdler Conan Doyle
publicly stated and actually believed
that Houdini could do this because he
could be materialized his body then
materialized again somewhere else
cool now obviously Houdini was a
magician it was a trick yeah all he did
to escape from those one there were only
so many different kinds of locks and
prison cells at that time period he
researched all of them right he had keys
and lock picks for every single one he
would research the place where he was
going before then and take the correct
lock picks now most of the places they
were he would be strip naked and he
would be searched yeah but what he would
do
was his wife Bess would put the lockpick
in her mouth and then before he was put
in the jail she kissed him for good luck
and slip it in there with her tongue all
right and then he would just unlock him
so he was quick obviously and he was
really you know flexible right so he
could get out of anything there's a
little guy - yeah he was about five foot
five yeah yeah so you know there was
nothing there was no trick about you
know he was just a trick if he wasn't d
materialized what's the trick it was a
plan yeah yeah like I said it was a lot
of research he did a lot of research to
figure out how to do all this stuff and
he trained himself how to do all these
things but Arthur Conan Doyle just would
not have it yeah he thought that Harry
was really a medium and
that and that that was why he was going
around debunking all these other mediums
was because he didn't want anybody to
know that that's how he was doing his
[ __ ] and nothing would convince him
otherwise that's nothing
that's a crass a creative way of looking
at right I know so
so Houdini like I said he he kept trying
to convince he's like look what what can
I do to convince you he's like check it
out okay so he says to Arthur Conan
Doyle he's like I will show you that I
can do like in a trick all this this
kind of [ __ ] that you're seeing it at
seances and I'll and I'll tell you it's
just trick so ok Doyle says okay so so
Houdini
he gives um Arthur Conan Doyle like a
slate yeah a chalkboard or whatever
Doyle hangs it on a wall in his room now
Houdini says he has five cork balls
mm-hm
and he tells doing you pick one of these
you put it in that white paint yeah okay
now he's like you take a piece of paper
you take that piece trip you can go
wherever you want to you go outside this
house you can go walk around the block
whatever and he's like can you write
something on that piece of paper with
that paint and he's like and then you
fold it up you printed and then you come
back so Doyle he takes the he takes cork
ball with the paint on it he takes the
piece of paper he goes three blocks down
the street like around the corner [ __ ]
like that he shades the paper yeah so no
one can see it yeah and then there's
somebody in the back of the house like
guarding Houdini so he didn't fall over
or nothing like that so he writes
something on a piece of paper and folded
up and comes back and then Houdini tells
Doyle Doyle gets back to the house and
he says now take that paint that white
ball dip it in the paint now just set it
on that slate so Doyle sets it on the
slate and the ball starts to move on the
slate and it spells out the word what
Doyle wrote on the ball and Doyle
flipped the [ __ ] out of course yet but
Houdini said to him he's like it's a
trick yeah but he's like you know him
and the other end oil and the other guy
that were there were like well how did
you do it was who do you like I might
tell you that I'm a magician I'm gonna
tell you how I did [ __ ] trick but
that put Houdini like in kind of a bad
position so I can't tell you how I did
the trick because I'm Rajesh
you don't do that right and but he's
like all I'm telling you is it wasn't
supernatural right I did it I want to
say that and here's but the weird thing
is I've read that no one is be able to
replicate that's Rick did it really
happen or did somebody make up a story
about that I don't know that's why I'm
saying this this was this was something
that I'd this this was one of the early
the the attempts that Houdini made to
try to show Doyle that Aldous that
seemingly magic things could be done I
mean I have seen other magicians do that
kind of trick yeah that's weird and
again work ball yes bells f7e there's no
way you could use a magnet yeah and
actually the UM he did Houdini had done
tricks like that previously like in his
in his previous you know career similar
to that yeah so I have no idea how he
did it but he and he wouldn't tell
anybody
it is pretty a pretty freaky I'd have to
see that myself it's pretty see that for
myself but apparently that's how the
trick but that would been a badass trick
that was a good trick but like I said
that [ __ ] kind of backfired because
Doyle was like there's no way you could
have done that right if it wasn't like
supernatural it wasn't magic so it you
know like I said it didn't have the
desired effect okay so okay good that
okay now we're gonna take a break and
when I come back I'm gonna talk some
more about Arthur Conan Doyle and you
know the kind of thing that really kind
of yeah I'll step there friendship don't
skip these commercials yeah yeah is a
free show people we need commercials we
have sponsors that we have - okay so
yeah here we go so we'll be back in just
a few minutes
Oh cast dead sexy podcasts
I'm your host Armand Rose Amelia Fridays
exclusively on project Entertainment
Network where I interview authors
publishers
genders orest s-- filmmakers narrators
the lady from walmart whoever i feel
like talking to that's every friday arm
cast right here on project entertainment
network if you're into cosplay corset
ruiz steampunk gothic or rockabilly
clothing shoes and accessories then you
must visit subculture corsets and
clothing either online at
www.haddadtoyota.com code thirteen
o'clock and receive a ten percent
discount on your entire order and if
you're a full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carries sizes four through 4x
and they have men's clothing as well
that's subculture corsets calm and use
discount code thirteen o'clock for a 10%
discount go check out their website now
subculture corsets calm or when
traveling through jacksonville florida
stop in and check out their store at the
avenues mommy
mr. frank the song is the showcase
podcast with Azzaro fiction genre and
those you're right weird and read weird
are gonna love the bizarre and weird
fiction grills so join us here every
Monday presented exclusively by the
project
[Music]
[Music]
there's harrows real and imaginary and I
write about them all paranormal
nonfiction
[Music]
go to WWJD ashbrook comm or search
Amazon for the Jenny Ashford author page
okay Arthur Conan Doyle yeah now so like
I said kind of a contentious friendship
a little bit but it was still okay at
this point although like I said Doyle
believed Houdini was magic Houdini was
trying to convince him otherwise it was
a bromance it was a brownie but it went
sour anyway so yeah and the way it went
sour and this is actually kind of a sad
story but um so Conan Doyle was on one
of his lecture tours and while he was on
one of his lecture tours um he was in
you know the same areas Houdini when
Houdini was touring around so you know
um Conan Doyle and his wife Lady Jean
they asked Houdini and his wife Beth to
come and stay with them for a little
vacation for a few days and you know
they were good buds and everything like
that so okay they went and stayed with
the with the Doyle and while they were
there lady Jean Arthur Conan Doyle's
wife she asked Houdini if he would like
it if she would try to contact his
mother
okay now Houdini was actually on board
with this because like I said yeah he
was skeptical yeah he was debunking but
he really wanted somebody to be able to
contact to contact his mother right
because he had loved her so much
right and lady Jean you know Lady Jane
and Sir Arthur Conan Doyle they were his
best friends I mean you know so of
course he was gonna let and and he even
said like before this happened he's like
you know I I'm gonna keep an open mind
about this I'm really
hoping that she'll finally be able to
come through for me all this other kind
of stuff okay so they had a seance at
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's house and Lady
Jean was the medium now almost
immediately lady Jean went into a trance
okay and then she had all this she did a
lot of automatic writing type of stuff
and she she started writing on the piece
of paper and it was supposedly from
Houdini's mother Cecilia okay now most
of the stuff she wrote she wrote quite a
lot yeah but most of the stuff she wrote
was just kind of the kind of stuff that
mediums usually tell you is like it oh
I'm so happy to be able to talk to you
really general aren't the Conan Doyle's
awesome they're letting you know for
letting this happen and all this other
kind of stuff
and you know thank you thank you and all
this other stuff I you know it's
wonderful where I am I'm in heaven it's
so wonderful to talk to you and stuff
like that now Houdini started getting a
little upset about this and according to
all said what you know why don't why
don't you ask if your mother can read
your mind
so Houdini said okay and so then so they
asked that you know can you read my mind
and and through lady Jeanne you said yes
she could and then that that would be
awesome so then she started writing even
more but it wasn't anything substantive
really right you know it was just the
same kind of stuff like you doing a
horoscope yeah like it was like a
horoscope so at the end of the seance
Houdini was kind of bummed out and the
reasons he was bummed out were were many
one the day of the seance was his
mother's birthday okay she had not
mentioned this yeah second on the piece
of paper where a lady Jean had done the
automatic writing she had made a cross
like a Christian
Krauss yeah ladies mother what's Jewish
Jewish yeah she would not have paid
across probably the most damning was
that Houdini's mother could not write
English okay yeah
in fact she could barely read or write
at all okay yeah um and she can only
speak broken English right you know on
obviously all this stuff that was
written was written in perfect English
yeah he was like my mother couldn't
speak English so and now because Houdini
felt bad about this now also also when
he had asked if his mother could read
his mind um he had deliberately thought
of a friend of his whose name was Powell
and that's what he had been thinking
so that's he said if it was really my
mother she would have come up with that
all right if she knew what I was
thinking now it was weird though because
after the seance Houdini wrote the word
Powell on a piece paper he's like that's
what I was thinking now Arthur Conan
Doyle coincidentally a friend of Doyle's
named Powell of a different guy yeah had
died three days before huh so he thought
that Harry was using his medium powers
okay yeah you know what I mean these
like oh my god he knew about my friend
that died yeah but it was written it was
a different guy he was talking about now
Houdini did not really want to be I mean
they were still his friends so he didn't
want to [ __ ] on them right yeah and ruin
the vacation and say all this stuff is
like that was not my mother
yeah so they finished out the visit you
know and then the the Doyles went you
know went away and stuff like that and
Houdini actually waited quite a long
time before he came out and said you
know they that was not my mother right
you know they didn't contact my mother
now he didn't necessarily think that
they were trying to [ __ ] with him right
because they were his friends right but
he thought
they had diluted themselves so much that
they leaving it into believing it that
they actually thought they were talking
to his mother because he didn't want to
believe that they were trying to fool
him we're trying to fool him
deliberately right like you know they
were nice people right he just thought
they were self-deluded um but you know
in 1922 like this was probably about six
months after the seance six months or
more you know he did come out and make a
public statement saying you know that
that was not my mother he said about the
indoor process yeah yeah so so the
Doyles were very mad they thought that
Houdini was being deliberately blind
yeah that he didn't want to see it
you know and all this other stuff words
Houdini felt that you know they they
were the ones that were being blind
because they were like you know
obviously you know that wasn't so that
was kind of so their friendship was kind
of tense and then you know the whole
thing with Margery happened and Arthur
Conan Doyle was a huge advocate of
Margery you know the naked medium and he
was very very upset that Houdini had
discredited her so much so that was kind
of the end of their friendship and it
was kind of sad because after Houdini
died best found a bunch of books on
spiritualism like in his stuff that he
had been wanting to give to Arthur Conan
Doyle and she tried to give them to him
and he said I don't think that he would
have wanted me to have them because they
ended up on such a bad note okay so that
was kind of a sad story now now
Houdini obviously he died in 1926 on
Halloween after a Miss aimed punch to
the stomach which he wasn't prepared for
yeah yeah I remember that story because
he used to go around saying because he
had those you know abs and everything
yes yeah punch me in the stomach
I mean stomach yeah dude punched you do
my him when he wasn't ready yeah and it
ended up rupturing his appendix and he
got
sepsis and he died yeah now before he
died like I said he had been you know
hoping that there was some legitimacy to
this whole talking to the dead type of
thing so before he died he had actually
set up with a bunch of his friends like
various codes you know so whoever dies
first you know we're gonna try and
contact each other now probably the most
famous of these codes he had established
with his wife Bess and he had set it up
with her he said now if I die first you
know and I'm gonna try and contact you
this is what I'm gonna say and it was a
code between them so for a year or two
after Houdini died Bess first started
doing kind of seances are trying to talk
to him on her own she you know every
Sunday she had a little shrine to him
with a candle and a picture and stuff
and she would try to talk to him but she
couldn't she couldn't um you know hear
anything she couldn't hear him and then
she got to a point where she was going
to offer ten thousand dollars to any
medium that could bring her a message
from him that was legitimately from him
it was this code that they had worked
out now no one could do that she kept
getting a bunch of cranks and stuff like
that but then in 1928 there was this
medium named Arthur Ford and he
contacted Bess and said that Houdini's
mother had come to him hmm
and he gave Houdini's mother's last word
forgive huh he said that that's what it
was well so that kind of impressed her
yeah now she did say that in the message
that Cecilia Houdini's mother had
apparently given to Ford that she had
called him Harry now that wasn't his
name his name was Eric and that's what
his mother had always called him because
that was his a real name so she thought
that was a little sketchy but you know
the idea that he had gotten the word
right impressed her so so they got in
touch now they had a seance in 1929 and
allegedly Arthur Ford produced the code
that Houdini and Bess had worked out Wow
this code when when it was you know
uncoated the message was
Rosabelle believe Rosabelle was their
favorite song hmm now it wasn't it so
that wasn't the only message which
probably would have been easy to work
out all right the word believe was coded
and the code was a was kind of a code
that Houdini and Bess had worked out
when you know back in the old days they
used to do it to let the act on stage
and they had this code worked out where
particular words you know were
signifiers of particular letters right
so you know the message that he actually
gave was the correct coded one and when
it was decoded it said Rosabelle believe
the actual message that he gave was
actually Rosabelle
answer tell pray answer look tell answer
answer tell see these words answer tell
pray those were letters so answer was B
right L was a you know so so she was she
was really impressed and stoked right
because she thought Houdini contacted
her right a couple years after he died
codes yeah and she actually published
you know an ad in the paper that said he
gave me the code it's correct Houdini
has spoken to me right but here's the
thing this is where the whole thing gets
kind of sketchy now only a couple of
days after the seance and after she said
yes Houdini has talked to me and yes I
got the code
the skeptics came out and said one
that their code maybe wasn't as unknown
as she thought because there had been a
biography of Houdini that had come out
like a year or two before and that code
had been detailed in there so someone
could have figured it out right the code
was detailed but the cook was given or
he's outlined see that's the thing it
was kind of outlined so it was was it
possible I don't think it would have
been I don't know it's like I don't know
how hard it would have been for some
time to figure it out
but see the thing is the the initial
thing that that got her interested in
the medium Arthur Ford was because of
him saying that he had talked to
Houdini's mother and Houdini's mother
had said the word forgive but that that
could have leaked and actually some
people say it did that there was an
interview or that had been published
that Houdini had been waiting right to
hear that word right so it so it wasn't
like that was totally unknown so that
could have been faked
dude just wanted to make his $10,000
right yeah now a little less now some
people said like a tabloid article came
out a couple days after the seance and
it made the allegation that Arthur Ford
and Bess Houdini had collaborated on
this like she liked like he had bought
the code off her or something like that
and they were doing it as like a
publicity stunt right that crossed my
mind to however to some Houdini
merchandise urged to do something yeah
maybe you revived another guy's career
right but the thing is she wasn't she
wasn't dating Ford was she not that
anyone ever suggested I don't think
anyone's ever suggested that all right
now she got kind of upset about that and
she published a you know she published a
letter in the paper and she said you
know she's like if I had just wanted
publicity
I could have done it years ago she's
like I've been getting messages the
were supposedly from Houdini from
mediums all over the world she's like I
could have publicised some of that if I
really wanted it all right and um you
know and she said I don't she's like I'm
not going back on the stage I'm not
going on a lecture tour she was older
then and she's like and I don't need the
money
it's like Houdini had lots of money left
her all his money and she you know she
said I'm quite comfortable and you know
so she she was kind of offended I think
that people would suggest that now later
on she would renounce Arthur Ford how so
and say and I think it was only a year
or two later she said you know I that it
didn't happen like that or he didn't
give me the code or she later said no
one has ever given me the code so I
don't know if she found out that Ford
had fooled her right did he get the ten
thousand no he never did but the thing
is best never really gave up hope of
hearing from him of from Houdini I mean
quite famously for ten years after he
died on Halloween night she would have a
seance and tried to get in contact with
him and she never did and actually and I
actually played a little bit of that
final recording at the beginning of the
show if you don't listen to that was
that was from the final seance in 1936
where she put the candle out and she
said she wasn't going to try anymore and
her famous quote at the time was ten
years is long enough to wait for any man
she said she hadn't heard from him in
ten years and so she thought she wasn't
that's odd that's odd that she said that
he gave the code and then later later
recanted it yeah that's yeah they're not
really sure what the deal with that was
like I don't know if I mean most of the
stuff she said about about why she
wouldn't have conspired with him you
know it made sense if she wanted
publicity she could have gotten it she
need the money yeah and Thord never got
the money she never paid him that
$10,000 so I don't know like I said I
don't know if later on she found out
that he had figured out the code you
know by some underhanded means and she
was maybe too embarrassed right okay but
she did recount and she did Bree can't
later on and she wasn't named public why
really well not really yeah like I said
there was a lot of kind of controversy
surrounding it okay but um you know so
after ten years you know I'll show you
what though man Houdini
he was an iron will little dude yeah I
mean they'd lock him in boxes and throw
him off of bridges and everything yeah
they just put him in those big milk cans
and like walk him all up it was like
full water like that it was like super
physically fit back in the back in a
time when dudes didn't work out pretty
cool I mean yeah and he was super
flexible he'd get out of anything like I
said that was what that was one of his
most famous things he could get up he
could get out of any cell and he had
that Chinese water torture cell the tank
where you would like hang upside down
and you know elected suddenly one of his
acts live pretty cool yeah no yeah he
seemed like a really he seemed like a
good dude and but actually like I said
you know Bess herself died in 1943 sadly
never never heard again from Houdini but
the tradition lives on okay as magicians
groups all over the world every
Halloween they have a seance and track
us back to Danny not seriously obviously
but it's just kind of a ritualistic kind
of fun thing they do and they try to
talk to him but uh you know so that's
that's all of that I guess but it's kind
of what he's making funny way okay so so
yeah I think I covered everything I
wanted to cover I hope I don't forget
anything I have like 12 pages and notes
and priming but okay so hopefully you
found that interesting and
anything else about a Houdini they're
not it will not at the moment
decimal we already got me started on the
any move merchandise
well now you want Houdini much of that
yes do you think I should make a Houdini
shirt can I am I allowed to do that I
don't know it was speaking of shirts
yeah we still have those five shirts at
asel calm / 13 o'clock so if you want to
go check those out still got the same
five designs might build a routine you
want to put my last yeah I doubt him
allowed but I'll see and if you liked
our show please subscribe to our youtube
show or listen to us on project
entertainment network or go to the
project entertainment network patreon
page and throw them a buck or two also
you can follow us on twitter at 13
o'clock podcast and go like our facebook
page 13 o'clock podcast all the regular
stuff i say at the end you know how it
goes blah blah blah blah blah blah he's
such a dick I know I love you it's okay
okay alright so be sure to tune in next
Tuesday we have no idea what the topic
will be because we don't decide until
like the day's work this we're totally
disorganized but you know I'm sure it'll
be interesting probably yeah yeah
alright alright see you guys next
Tuesday
you